on saturday a contract that we had been
expecting for weeks to sean watson
agreeing to terms with the texans on his
second deal before he was ever in a
position where he was going to take any
hits potentially get injured the injury
risk shifts to the texans with a
four-year extension on top of the two
years that watson had left on his first
round rookie contract from 2017 he gets
paid a lot of money
to compare his contract year by year
through the first four seasons with the
patrick mahomes deal whether it's
signing bonus whether it's money
guaranteed for skill injury and cap at
signing cash flow year one two three
four
all metrics better than the patrick
mahomes deal and after four years watson
began to contract for two more seasons
and focusing on as the agents presumably
did doing a deal that compared very
favorably to patrick mahomes there's
some other quarterback contracts you
could look at and say those deals may be
better those quarterbacks got more fully
guaranteed money at signing those
quarterbacks have better cash flow
through one year two year three years
four years one name right off the top of
the head ryan's hannah hill who has 118
million over four years with his
four-year deal with the titans deshawn
wants to make 110 million over the next
four years which guy would you rather
have over the next four years all due
respect to ryan tannehill i doubt that
anyone would say give me tana hill over
watson and yet tana hill over the next
four seasons will make eight million
more than watson
and after those four seasons tannehill
will be a free agent again watson will
be under contract for two more years so
uh and there are other contracts as well
that will compare favorably both to
watson and mahomes watson compares
favorably to my homes the reality is the
mahomes deal in the early years is so
bad
all due respect it doesn't take much
to compare favorably to the first few
years of the patrick mahomes contract
but the good news is
watson was able to avoid
getting crammed into that same
pigeonhole of a long-term ultra
long-term ridiculous long-term contract
like the deal that my home signed the
chiefs that's going to be a battle for
more quarterbacks to fight as they try
to get their contracts dak prescott
coming up soon others will be following
suit like kyler murray eventually lamar
jackson after this season when he's
eligible for a second deal it's always
better to take a shorter term contract
and have flexibility
than to to lock yourself in for a dozen
years like patrick mahomes did now i
understand why i did it i get it
it's his right to do it but when we look
across the board at all quarterback
contracts and compare them some are
going to be better than others and the
quarterbacks who commit for 12 years
are going to be in a tough spot to be
able to say i got the best of the
contracts watson's deal
better than my homes the reality there
are other deals out there better than
both and it makes you wonder how long
until the players realize it and how
long until the market
gets to a point where both watson and
mahomes will say i think it's time to
redo those deals because maybe they
weren't as good as they ultimately could
have been
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports